[Music]
we used to do a bit long time ago on our
uh old show called if they made it
that's where we took pictures of famous
people and we melded them together well
times and technology have changed so
tonight we're introducing a new segment
where we take video of two names in the
news and we combine them because
it wastes your time and it could be fun
it's called
if they melded
first up we've melded hillary clinton
and stephen tyler
i just want to tell you i'm going to
tell you
to keep it together
because the whole world is watching you
[Applause]
[Music]
attracted actually
i've got taylor sw
i'm kind of scared yeah i'm scared and
attractive
ladies and gentlemen taylor swift and
harry styles
i don't really talk about my love life i
kind of sing about it a lot music is my
way of understanding what i'm feeling
[Music]
and finally you asked for it we're
giving it to you president obama and
nicki minaj
[Music]
i would like getting everybody involved
in the house singing
you know lo and behold there are tons of
girls and tons of boys who
appreciate all that craziness and know
[Applause]